michael lohan speaks out on Lindsay's  engagement what he's only telling ET  michel couldn't be happier for his  daughter he tells ET quote I'm so happy  that Lindsay a sound true happiness it's  written all over both of them I'm really  really pleased with where she is in life  and I'm happy for her the 29 year old  actress is set to wed 22 year old  Russian business air Igor tarvatha  Michael also tells ET the whole family  was in New York to watch Lindsay take  the stage at the Duran Duran concert on  tuesday night she shared this shot  showing off her new sparkler for the  first time she's really happy Michael  who's had a rocky relationship with his  daughter over the years says that he's  quote so thankful that they all got  together and had a great time and adds  quote Igor is a great guy they are  definitely in love okay guys are you  happy for Lindsay and what do you think  of the engagement let's chat over on  Twitter and thanks for watching